unconventional from the off the party
started with words from the new monarch
I shall Endeavor to serve you with
loyalty
respect
before the grounds of Windsor Castle
erupted into a royal rest
it is the right word and uh yeah I mean
you should see the the king with his
foam and whistle is quite something
the twenty thousand
thou famous gate crushers
tree and
Charles hop for a bit of fun
while not all the pre-recorded sketches
landed anytime
[Music]
from the new Doctor Who performing
Shakespeare
with my unworthiest hand
this holy Shrine alongside the Royal
Ballet and Royal Opera winter Castle's
first ever public concert proving quite
the cultural Melting Pot
[Music]
a staple at any party singer Lionel
Richie managing to get even the King on
his feet dancing sort of well I got my
request list now who it came from I have
a sneaky suggestion of that it it came
from the title well it was a night of
Celebration including a spectacular
National light show it was also a
reminder from the King to protect what's
precious what do we do to you and to
Nature we ultimately do to ourselves
I think it's incredible to have somebody
of in such a powerful position have a
really you know honest and true interest
and voice on on sustainability
a fittingly Regal performance from pop
royalty Katy Perry no actual fireworks
but a big finale take that reuniting for
a mass sing-along but the real star of
the show The King and his castle the
ultimate backdrop for a royal party to
remember coaches Spencer Sky News in
Windsor